not only did square-enix show off a new
trailer for the Hitman game but we also
got some details on the upcoming beta
first the beta begins on februari 12 for
playstation 4 and februari 19th for PC
the only way as of now to get your hands
on the beta is to preorder a digital
copy of either the intro pack full
experience or the collector's edition
unfortunately if you pre-ordered the
physical edition of the game you will
not be able to participate in the beta
into beta you will be able to play the
games prologue which details when agent
47 first joined the ICA the Hitman beta
begins on PlayStation 4 at eight a.m.
pacific standard time and ends februari
15 at the same time unfortunately
progress in the beta will not carry over
into the full game the file size is four
point seven gigabytes Square Enix
assures us that this was not an
intentional reference to agent 47 some
other highlights from the FAQ are it
won't include contract modes the beta is
in English only you will need an
internet connection and once the beta
wraps up Square Enix will send out a
survey asking for your thoughts pitman
arrives on playstation 4 xbox one and pc
this march
you